people are listening to each other right
if you tell me you had 15 bodies I gotta
add an extra five because there's five
that you don't count there's five that
didn't put it down just five that lasted
a minute there's five that you didn't
really like so they don't so now you're
15 is really 20. okay okay and it's like
yo we don't ever get the truth and then
and you know what I have a daughter
right and
um I did been doing a lot of studying
right on psychology and people and lying
and they say that kids first learn that
they cannot Trump I don't mean to spoil
anybody's you know thing
kids learn that they cannot trust their
parents
when they find out that the holidays are
not really real
Santa Claus he's the bunny into fairy
okay so now for a man we just take I
take that basic principle that basic
concept and apply it to life right and
it's like well
how can a man trust a woman who can't be
honest
with her past
and then
when you when you really really dig deep
it's like men have to make exceptions
for women on a daily basis they do
and I do think you're right like I don't
I don't necessarily agree that all men
can like tell off the bat with a woman's
body count is because we can all we can
all think of that friend that like no
one would ever know or that girl I think
of like girls on my team but the thing
is like a girl sleeping around it hurts
herself it's not it's not necessarily
like because you're just more likely to
leave it's it's hard to for those girls
to stay and that's what I I asked my mom
this question because I always I always
like to ask like the older generation to
see their you know and I I asked her I'm
like you're you're hell friends my mom's
like I don't have any
[Laughter]
but like what happens to the girls that
like from your high school or whatever
that like every like Town bicycles I
don't think they called it back in the
day or whatever
and she's like no I was like would they
still get married and she would say yes
but they were the first divorced but now
like those women probably aren't even
gonna get married because 50 of women um
that hit 30 are single and childless and
then they're saying that like there's
gonna be such a rise in like single
women that there's more single women
that are going to be homeless there's
gonna be more single women on benefits
and 50 of women between the ages like of
marriageable age between the age of 20
and 25 and 45 are going to be single and
childless so much that like JP Morgan is
investing in like cat food dog food wine
Etc that's crazy I got my kids
wow and and that real thing yeah yeah I
mean like that's 50 of women that hit 30
are single and childless white women no
no no no
in America right in America if you're
gonna do marriage rates like buy race
um I I want to say it's like Asians have
it the best then then white like the
highest marriage rates like Asian women
then white women are Indian really
um I think Asian is like Indian that's
included in Asian that's part of Asia
right I could be I could be yeah yeah I
mean join the continent wise yeah yeah
but so um it's like Asians on top and
then second white and then um I think
it's Hispanic then black
in terms of the marriage rates in the
U.S anyway and the U.S is so terrible
that I and and you know this is this is
just great to even talk about
the average single parent household in
the world
excluding the US is eight percent
okay the U.S is 24 this was as of 2019
so yeah 24 so now what basically one in
four kids grow up without a parent and I
would I'd be curious what percent like
are divorced parents too so they're
asking what is the reason
well the reason is I think that there's
there's a lot of different Norms that
are trying to be pushed right
um I agree and I think that's the reason
one of the Norms is that women can sleep
with whoever they want and how many men
that they want that's one of the reasons
you know what I'm saying and I think
that that is detrimental because at the
end of the day no man wants to take care
of a woman that has a lot of bodies I I
don't care what anybody says but
I mean I just think it's like women
batting out of their league a lot and
they just get pregnant by the guy that
they can't lock down that's that's what
I think
I think it's like like the fours five
sixes trying to lock down the eights
nines of tens and they get pregnant by
them because half of the time like they
weren't even in a relationship yeah I
see anywhere and that's another thing so
I was gonna go and like to to piggyback
off of that but now we're talking about
what are women Desiring do women are
Desiring the men with the money right
there's a on the shade room I forgot her
name she posted don't marry for love
married for money well guess what
there's only 15 percent that make over
six figures and only like seven percent
that make over
um what's it called 250 000. so now what
do you marry there's not a lot of
options so you're sharing men right but
then again on the same on the same token
men can't have more than one woman but
the there's only about what 28 of men in
America make up a hundred percent of the
whip of the kids in America
rounding up right 30 of the men make up
100 of the kids that means women don't
want seventy percent of their men
so now but but then again they don't
want to share a man but other women more
career driven now and independent and
now it's the opposite where men cannot
or men feel insecure that they're not
able to keep up with a woman that is
making a certain amount of money so they
decide that they do not want to get
married men don't men don't care if
you're independent they do no they don't
I'm telling them they do okay personal
experience okay well I'll tell you I I
do pretty well with my channel I play
like 10 people and I'm telling you men
don't give a [ __ ] like they don't care
at all they only they only what you say
you pull ten I employ ten people I
employ 10 people with my channel roughly
I don't I don't I have to count all the
contract I don't know
and I'm saying like like men don't care
they just care when you throw it in your
face so when you say it like when you
say things I don't think you understand
like how men hear when you're saying I'm
strong I'm independent like men want to
be needed when you say I don't need you
like that's a red flag too guy so when
yeah like when you come at a guy and you
say like I'm strong I'm independent like
the way they see that is I don't need
you why would I want to be with a woman
that like doesn't need me and so you
think that women are just telling men
I'm strong I'm independent yeah yeah I
think it's the attitude that comes with
it because I've talked to him I talked
to people four times a week so like this
is just what the men tell me is they say
like because like that's something I got
when I was younger like my mom would say
like oh you're so good at things and
like boys are intimidated by you and I
was like a teenager in high school you
know
she's like you're tall and but
um but anyways uh but I hear this
narrative but the older I get I'm like
that's not true like he even said he
likes a girl that like is yeah but you
guys are 29 and 25. so it realistically
I don't even think that you'll want to
get married at 25 years old
yeah yeah I would like to be married
like that's I think I would prefer to be
married like sooner rather than later
well yeah I mean
my 25 degrees
I can I can want to be a millionaire it
doesn't mean I am like it I mean yeah
listen everybody wants to be married
it's just not everybody but most people
want to be married if they find them
right person but with that right person
is nobody knows because people change
their mind based on what the society as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible